Transcriber: Esra Çakmak
Gözden geçirme: Ozay Ozaydin
Merhabalar ben İbrahim Özdemir.
Çevre felsefecisi ve çevre
ahlakı hocasıyım.
İnsanın doktora tezini seçmesi
eş seçmesi gibidir.
Sevmediğiniz bir konuda bir tez
seçerseniz ömür boyu mutsuz olursunuz.
Mutsuz olduğunuzda da öğrencilerinize
bir şey veremezsiniz.
Onun için tez seçerken dikkatli edin.
Başkasının etkisinde kalmayın.
Bazen insan hocasının etkisiyle bir konu
seçer ve ömür boyu onu bir yük gibi taşır.
Doksanlı yılların başında çevre
felsefesini çalışacağımı söylediğimde,
rahmetli hocam dedi,
“Boşver bu konuyu.
Bu bir modadır.
Bugün var, yarın yok.
Daha ciddi bir konu çalış.”
Ben ısrar ettim.
Hocamı kırmadan ikna ettim
ve tezimi yazdım.
Keşke hocam haklı çıksaydı.
Keşke çevre bir moda olsaydı da geçseydi.
Ama şu anda dünyanın gündemine bakınız.
Ülkemin gündemine bakınız.
İklim kaynaklı sorunlar hepimizi
etkilemeye devam ediyor.
İşin diğer güzel bir tarafı ise,
ilk müslüman çevreci bilim
adamı olduğumu anladım.
Bu konuda doktora yapan ilk kişiymişim.
Bu da beni başta Mikhail Gorbaçov, Nelson
Mandela, Dalai Lama gibi
dünya liderleriyle aynı masada,
aynı toplantılara katılma imkânı sundu.
Bundan da çok mutlu oldum.
Bu salonun girişinde
İbni Sina Oditoryumu yazıyor.
Bu binanın,
Üsküdar Üniversitesi’nin en büyük salonu.
Onun için burada İbni Sina adının olması,
İslam bilim geleneğinde bilime,
bilim adamına olan saygının,
hürmetin bir ifadesi.
Ben de konuşmama hazırlanırken
İbni Sina'ya başvurdum.
Üstadım, Nevzat Tarhan Hoca senin adına
muhteşem bir salon yapmış.
Orada konuşacağım.
İklim değişikliğinden bahsedeceğim.
Bana ne tavsiye edersin.
Dedi ki, “İbrahim, yazdığım
El-Kanun fi’t-Tıb’da her şey var.”
Kitap on beşinci yüzyılda Latinceye,
on sekizinci ve on dokuzuncu yıllarda
bütün diğer Avrupa dillerine,
yine on sekizinci yüzyılda Mustafa Tokadi
Efendi tarafından Osmanlı Türkçesine
ve yirminci yüzyılda da Türkçe
Türkçesine çevrilmiş.
Orada her şey var.
Kitabı aldım, bir baktım
hakikaten her şey var.
Diyor ki, insan sağlığı
suyun, toprağın, havanın sağlıklı
olmasına bağlı.
İnsanlar bir yerde sağlıklı hayat şartları
yoksa başka yere göç ederler.
Bu da normaldir
ve İbni Sina gördüğünüz gibi burada
El-Kanun fi’t-Tıb kitabında
bunu detaylarla açıklıyor.
Daha sonra,
çocukluğuma gittim.
Ben de bir köyde doğdum.
Ama 1969 yılında Ay’a ilk ayak
basıldığında o zaman televizyonumuz yoktu.
Radyodan haberleri takip ediyordum.
Nasıl oldu diye.
Bütün ayrıntıları radyodan takip ettim.
Gazetelerde okumaya çalıştım.
Fakat daha sonra Ay’a ilk ayak basan
astronotların hikâyelerini dinleyince
onları en büyüleyen şeyin ayak bastıktan
sonra dönüp Dünya’ya baktıklarında
hepsinin nefesinin kesilmesi oldu.
Karşılarında ilk defa şu Mavi Gezegen ilk
defa görüldü, ilk defa resmi çekildi.
Bakınız ne kadar güzel.
O aydan diğer uzayın boşluğuna
karanlıklarına baktılar.
Acaba başka bir yerde hayat var mı?
Su var mı?
Okyanus var mı?
Hiçbir yerde yok.
Hâlâ daha arıyorlar.
Milyarlarca dolar harcanıyor.
Birçok bilim insanı bu uğurda
hayatını feda ediyor.
Ama henüz hayat bulamadık.
Onun için tek gezegenimiz dünyamız.
Ama gezegenimiz hasta.
Yakın bir zamanda hepimiz
ateş ölçerle tanıştık.
Üniversiteye girerken, toplu taşıma
kullanırken, uçağa binerken
ateşimiz ölçüldü.
Neden?
Çünkü vücut ateşimizin biraz fazla
olması hastalık belirtisi idi.
Peki dünyamızın sağlığı nasıl?
İç açıcı mı?
Her gün televizyonlarda bunları
bize sunuyorlar bir haber gibi
ama bazı insanların hayatı yok oluyor.
Bazı insanlar da hayat boyu bunun
sonuçlarına katlanıyor.
Bunlardan birisi iklim göçmenleri.
Suriye göçmenlerinden,
Ukrayna göçmenlerinden,
Afgan göçmenlerinden bahsetmiyorum.
Dünyada ben bu konuyu çalıştığım
için biliyorum.
Bir zamanlar konuşma yaparken
40 milyon mülteci var.
60 milyon oldu, 80 milyon oldu.
Şu anda 224 milyon.
Gelecek senaryolarına baktığımızda
800 milyondan bahsediliyor.
İşte görüyorsunuz Kastamonu’yu,
görüyorsunuz ondan sonra
orman yangınlarını.
Bütün dünyada, Akdeniz havzasında
geçen hafta ormanlar yandı.
Biz artık iklim değişikliği var mı,
çevreyle ilgili sonuçlar var mı
bunu tartışmıyoruz.
Geçen yıl bunu hepimiz yaşadık.
Ormanlar yanarken sadece ormanlarımız
yanmadı, ciğerlerimiz yandı.
Ben bir orman yangınında bulundum.
Oradaki canlıların haykırışı
bazen hâlâ kulaklarımda.
Peki ne yapabiliriz?
Bunların nedenleri ne?
Bu kuraklığın nedenlerine bakınız.
Burada bir iklim göçmenini görüyoruz.
Bunların üzerinde düşünmemiz gerekiyor.
Marmara ölüyor, diyorlar.
Ölüm iki türlüdür.
Birisi doğal ölümdür.
Duyduğumuz zaman “İnnâ lillâhi
ve innâ ileyhi râciûn” deriz.
“Allah’tan geldik, O’na dönüyoruz.
Allah rahmet eylesin.”
Ama bir de eğer doğal değilse
hemen sorarız.
Acaba neden ölmüş?
Acaba Marmara neden ölüyor?
Hiç bunu düşündük mü?
Hâlâ Marmara denizine
bölgedeki fabrikaların atıkları
filtre edilmeden dökülüyorsa,
hâlâ Marmara’nın etrafındaki kasabalar,
şehirler kanalizasyonlarını
denizin dibine döküyorlarsa.
O zaman faili meçhul değil bunun.
Bakınız TÜBİTAK başkanımız
Profesör Doktor Hasan Mandal diyor ki,
“Lütfen Marmara ve Boğazlar’daki
balıklardan balıkları almayın.
Deniz ürünlerini tüketmeyin.
Çünkü Marmara canlı.
Marmara’nın canlı olduğunu değişen
dünya kavramımızla anladık.
On yedinci, on sekizinci yüzyıl
bilim anlayışına göre
tabiat cansızdı, ruhsuzdu, anlamsızdı.
Ama şimdiki bilim anlayışı öyle değil.
Post materyalist bilim anlayışında
tabiatın canlı olduğunu, anlamlı olduğunu
ve manevi bir değeri olduğunu görüyoruz.
Biz bunu ihmal ettik Marmara’da.
Onun için yarın bir gün
2050, 2060, 2070′de torunlarınız;
dedeciğim, neneciğim, Marmara ölürken
o zaman eğer tedbir almazsak,
bugünden bir değişim yapmazsak
o zaman sen ne yaptın,
bana nasıl bir dünya bıraktın
derse ne cevap vereceğiz?
Bunun üzerinde düşünmemiz lazım.
İklim göçleri dediğim gibi devam edecek.
Yani bunu şunun için söylüyorum.
Bu bütün dünyanın sorunu.
Bu iklimden kaynaklanan sorunları
çözmek için
mevcut ekonomik sistemi sürdürülemez.
Bunun için sürdürülebilir ekonomi
modelleri üzerinde çalışıyoruz.
Su kaynaklarını sürdürülemez.
Toprak, her şey sınırlı.
Allah’ın sınırlı yarattığı,
bir denge ile yarattığı bir alemde
biz sınırsız bir şekilde tüketince
bu yetmiyor.
Peki neler yapacağız?
Görüyorsunuz.
Bu sorunların asıl sorumlusu
biz insanlarız.
Kimimiz daha çok sorumlu, kimimiz daha az.
Mesele bu değil ama bilim eğer ilmi
kendimize mürşit edineceksek,
bilimi temel alacaksak,
66 ülkeden 234 bilim insanı
ulaştığı sonuç bu.
Son bu yaşadığımız sorunların
%95 oranında sorumlusu biziz.
Bu sorunları çözmemiz için önce
kendimizi değiştirmemiz lazım.
Kendimize bakış açımızı, dünyaya bakış
açımızı değiştirmemiz lazım.
Arkadaşım İngiltere Kraliçesi
olamadığın için üzülme
veyahut filan ülkenin başbakanı
veyahut çok ünlü birisi
olmadığın için üzülme.
Bu belki kapasitemiz dışındadır.
O zaman ama bir adım atarak kendini
değiştirebilirsin.
Bilgi temelinde
kendimizi dönüştürebiliriz.
Size iki örnek sunuyorum.
Bakınız bu iki örneği
seçmemde haksız değilim.
Bu salonun yüzde yetmişi hanımlar.
Dünyada çevreciliği başlatan hanımlar.
Hiç bilenlerle
bilmeyenler bir olur mu,
diyor kutsal kitabımız.
Burada da Rachel Carson
Sessiz Bahar kitabını yazdı
ve dünyada çevreci hareketin
adeta fitilini ateşledi.
Kendisi biyolog.
1958′li yıllarda alanda yaptığı
araştırmalarda;
tarımda kullanılan tarım ilaçlarının
yağmurlarla derelere,
derelerden göllere, denizlere kavuştuğunu
ve bu sırada her şeyi
öldürdüğünü keşfetti.
Başta DDT olmak üzere bunlara
karşı bir savaş başlattı.
Önce kimya sanayi, sonra kendi
devleti onunla mücadele etti.
Onunla alay edildi
ama o pes etmedi.
Bir yanda tutulduğu kanserle, bir yanda da
çevre sorunlarını savunmaya devam etti
ve çok geçmeden dünyada bir
bilinç değişimi oldu.
İlk Dünya Çevre Konferansı 1970′te
Stockholm’da toplandı.
1972′de, bu yıl 50.’si düzenlenecek
ve Üsküdar Üniversitesi olarak
biz de davetliyiz.
Bakınız, bir kadın neler yapıyor.
İkincisi bu Greta Thunberg.
İsveçli bir kız, mücadeleye başladığında
16 yaşındaydı.
Şimdi belki 18-19 yaşında.
Çok basit bir eylem yaptı.
Kimseyi taşlamadı,
kimseye bir şey yapmadı.
Eleştirmedi, sadece gittiği parlamentonun
önünde durdu.
“Bu cuma günü
ben okula gitmiyorum,” dedi.
Buradaki kullandığı metafor çok muhteşem.
“Çünkü bir insanın evi yanarken
okula gitmez.
İklim değişikliğinden dolayı
bu kadar sorunumuz var.
Siz parlamenterler olarak bize yalan
söylemeye devam ediyorsunuz.
Hükûmet olarak hiçbir şey yapmıyorsunuz.
Sizi protesto ediyorum.”
Dediler, “Önce okulunu bitir,
sonra bu işlerle uğraşırsın.”
ama o bunları dinlemedi.
Bir süre sonra bu eylem bütün
dünyaya yayıldı.
14 Mart 2019′da Nairobi’de bir toplantıya
katıldığımda baktım,
oradaki siyahi çocuklar da okula gitmiyor.
Ben de gittim.
“Yahu İsveçli bir kızın
grevinden size ne!”
Hayır, dediler.
Onun mesajı evrensel.
O biz Afrikalıların da daha insan onuruna
yakışır, daha iyi bir dünyada yaşamamız,
daha sağlıklı bir dünyada yaşamamız
için mücadele ediyor
ve daha sonra bizim ülkelerimiz
de katıldı.
En geç katılanlar demokrasinin
az olduğu ülkeler oldu
çünkü çevreci hareket ile demokrasi
arasında hep bir ilişki var.
Peki biz neler yapabiliriz?
Biz Üsküdar Üniversitesi olarak
elimizden geleni yapıyoruz.
Kamuoyunu bilgilendiriyoruz.
Rektörümüzün de desteğiyle Üsküdar'da
Çevre Ahlakı Forumu'nu kurduk.
Üsküdar Üniversitesi sıfır atık
konusunda Türkiye’nin ikinci üniversitesi
ve yine kendi çapımızda birçok
etkinlikler yapıyoruz
ama en önemlisi sizin yapacaklarınız.
Bu nedenle birinci adım:
Lütfen evimizin yandığını, evimizde
yangın olduğunu konuşun.
Bunu araştırın.
Bunu insanlara yayın.
Çevre sorunları diye sorunlarımız var.
Marmara’daki müsilajı anlamaya çalışın.
Gelecekte çocuklarımız
temiz su içebilecek mi?
Temiz hava soluyabilecek mi?
Bunu araştırın lütfen
ve en büyük şey;
gıda konusunda, ürünler konusunda
elimizden geldiği kadar
yerel marketlerden, üreticiden,
ürün almaya dikkat edelim.
Bu zincir belki bizim için,
İstanbul için zor olabilir
ama ben Anadolu’yu gezdiğimde
bunu birçok kişinin yaptığını gördüm.
Yakında Gaziantep, Hatay’ı gezdim.
İklim değişikliğinin sonuçlarını
çiftçilerimizin de anladığını gördüm.
Artık eskisi gibi, tarım ilaçlarına
her derde deva gibi saldırmıyorlar.
Ayrıca hayatın her gün pahalandığı
bir dünyada
kendi bahçenizi oluşturabilirsiniz.
Ben eşime Konfüçyüs’ün
dediği gibi içi kitap
ve dışı çiçek dolu
bir bahçe veremedim.
Ama eşim böyle bir balkonda
bir bahçe bize sağladı
ve burada yeşil soğanımızı,
teremizi, maydanozumuzu
kendimiz elde ediyoruz.
Bunu esasında birçoklarımız yapabilir
ve gıda konusundaki israfa dikkatinizi
çekmek istiyorum.
Bakınız, küresel gıda israfı
hızla artıyor.
Birleşmiş Milletler'in Çevre Programı'nın
2021 Gıda Atıkları Endeksi'ne göre
dünyada her yıl 931 milyon ton
gıda atığı var
ve Türkiye burada listenin üstlerinde.
Dünya ortalamasında kişi başına 74
kilogram gıda artığı varken
Türkiye’de bu 94.
Bizim kutsal kitabımız,
Allah israf edenleri sevmez diyor.
Evet, dediğim gibi birçok şeyi
değiştiremeyebiliriz
ama kendi hayat tarzımızı,
israfı önleyebiliriz
ve böylece çevre üzerindeki
büyük bir etkiyi azaltmış oluruz.
Her yıl on iki milyon hektar
orman yok oluyor.
Bunların bir kısmı iklim değişikliğinden
dolayı oluyor.
Birçok devlet bakınız, geçen
sene hazırlıksız yakalandık.
Ama bu yıl biraz daha hazırlıklıyız.
Evet, iklim değişimine bağlı
olarak ormanlar yanacak.
Ormanlar bir de ticari amaçlarla
yok ediliyor
ama İslam Peygamberi diyor ki, “Birinizin
elinde bir fidan varken
kıyamet kopuyor olsa bile
derhal onu diksin.”
Umutsuzluk yok, çaresizlik yok.
Ya zaten kıyamet kopuyor.
O beni ilgilendirmez.
Ben kıyametin kopuşunu önleyemem
ama elimdeki fidanı dikebilirim.
Müthiş bir umut, müthiş bir teşvik.
Onun için elimizden geldiği
kadar fidan dikelim.
Üsküdar Üniversitesinin
bir güzelliği daha var.
Çeşitli etkinliklerde ödül vermiyor.
Fidan sertifikası veriyor.
Sizin adınıza bir fidan dikiyor.
Allah gecinden versin, günü geldiğinde
dünyada dikili bir fidanım bile yok,
demeyeceksiniz.
Sertifikalı bir fidanınızın olduğunun
sertifikası var elinizde.
Bu da çok güzel bir etkinlik.
Anlamsız plaketler yerine
çok anlamlı bir şey.
Bir plaket ve Aşık Veysel.
Toprağı, tabiatı sevmemiz
lazım arkadaşlar.
Sadece ekonomik değerinden dolayı değil,
iki şairden örnek vereyim.
Âşık Veysel diyor ki,
Havaya bakarsam hava alırım
Toprağa bakarsam
Dua alırım.
Topraktan ayrılsam nerede kalırım?
Benim sadık yarim kara topraktır.
Şiirin gerisini okuyun.
Anadolu insanın hikmet anlayışının ne
kadar derin olduğunu göreceksiniz.
İkincisi Mary Oliver.
Amerikalı bir şair.
Kısa süre önce aramızdan ayrıldı.
Gazeteci soruyor,
“Güne nasıl başlıyorsun?”
Mesnevi’den bir şeyler okuyarak
sonra köpeğimle tabiatta gezerek.
“13. yüzyıldaki bir
şair size ne verebilir?”
Bana hayatı, toprağı öpmek için yüz
nedenim olduğunu gösteriyor.
Moda tuzağına düşmeden mütevazi olarak
yaşamak, lüzumsuz şeyleri almamak,
sırf moda diye tüketimi körüklememek.
Bu konuda en büyük örneğimiz Türkiye’nin
en büyük zenginlerinden olduğu hâlde
mütevazi bir hayat yaşayan
Hayrettin Karaca.
Ben onu özellikle seçtim.
Diğer çevreciler gibi bizim
de çevrecilerimiz var.
Yine alternatif enerjiyi kullanabiliriz
ve El Mizan Dünya Çevre Sözleşmesini
hazırlayan ekipte 5 kişilik grupta
Üsküdar Üniversitesi var.
Bu etkinlik, bu beyanname bu yıl Birleşmiş
Milletler’e sunulacak
ve hepinizin adına bir mesaj olacak.
Hepinize çok teşekkür ediyorum.